je pense que les français auraient été
me connais je me vois depuis très
longtemps mais beaucoup me connaissez
mal est en réalité si on considère que
l'élection présidentielle et je
considère c'est la rencontre d'un homme
d'une femme avec le peuple alors il faut
donner un peu de soi il faut montrer un
peu qui on est et au travers de mon
parcours bien je me suis construite si
aujourd'hui je considère que je suis
prête à être présidente de la république
c'est aussi parce que j'ai vécu des
épreuves des difficultés j'ai travaillé
j'ai échoué jeu j'ai fait des bêtises
parfois je les ai reconnus
voilà je je voulais leur dire tout ça je
pense que la personnalité ça qu'on ne
voyait pas ce que la personnalité c'est
ce qu'ils disent que vous allez faire et
surtout c'est ce qu'il dit la manière
dont vous allez le faire vous avez quand
même une histoire incroyable vous avez
huit ans un attentat a dévasté votre
appartement familial votre maman a
disparu du domicile familial du jour au
lendemain quand vous aviez saison c'est
vrai que vous avez quand même traversé
des épreuves incroyable votre votre
relation avec avec votre papa ils ont
toujours été compliquées c'est vrai que
vous avez quand même traversé des choses
que très peu de gens traversent est ce
que c'est ça aussi qui vous fait tenir
et qui fait qu' on a l'impression que
vous avez quand même un mental d'acier
c'est ce que c'est un parcours pas
commun on dit il faut que le coeur se
brise ou ce bronze bon alors oui bien
sûr toutes ces épreuves participe de ce
que je suis participe de la solidité qui
est la mienne aujourd'hui
participe de ce sang froid également
parce que l'expérience parce que je sais
que justement il ne faut pas se laisser
des motivés se laisser désespéré à la
moindre difficulté et des difficultés je
crois que j'en est confronté j'ai été
confronté à un certain nombre et cette
sérénité que j'ai aujourd'hui c'est
aussi la conséquence de tous ces
événements qui ont émaillé ma vie et qui
n'ont pas toujours effectivement été
très simple pensez qu'aujourd'hui un le
pen peut être président de la république
oui je le crois oui bien sûr qu'est ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui c'est possible
et que ça n'a jamais été possible avant
pas ce qui fait c'est une rencontre
c'est toujours pareil dans une rencontre
chacun fait un pas aussi vers l'autre
c'est que
justement j'ai tiré expériences du passé
que j'ai beaucoup travaillé le projet
que je présente aujourd'hui aux français
qui a une forme d'urgence aussi les
français prennent conscience aujourd'hui
y compris avec la guerre en ukraine
d'ailleurs que les choix qu'ils vont
faire dans moins d'un mois sont des
choix qui vont pas seulement déterminées
les cinq prochaines années je veux dire
sans des choix qui vont peut-être
déterminer les 50 prochaines années
est-ce qu'on maîtrise à nouveau nos
frontières est ce que on maîtrise notre
politique énergétique est-ce qu'on
maîtrise notre politique agricole et
donc est ce qu'on maîtrise notre
souveraineté alimentaire tous ces sujets
là vous comprenez bien c'est pas des
sujets pour dans les 5 pour les cinq
prochaines années c'est vraiment des
sujets structurants pour notre avenir
pour l'avenir de nos enfants et sur le
long terme